hello everyone welcome back to the
channel we've got another south by
southwest 2022 interview for you right
now for the movie linoleum colin jim ray
hello congratulations
i don't know how you made this movie
work but this is something else i've
never seen anything quite like it
i think that's a compliment i'll take it
i'll take it uh well that's great yeah
it was definitely a journey you know uh
but now we're here so we're all happy
yes so with the festival premiere our
audience likely will not know much about
your movie just yet so colin will you do
the honors and give us a brief
description of linoleum i sure will yeah
so it's a it's a sci-fi dramedy more um
you know sort of a family drama about uh
this
failing children's science tv show host
played by jim gaffigan who attempts to
build a diy rocket ship in his garage
uh meanwhile uh his wife is um thinking
he's insane but she's also dealing with
uh an entire sort of mid-life crisis of
her own
um and uh all of this is sort of brought
about when all these surreal events
start occurring in in their world so i
was reading a little bit about how the
genesis of the project wasn't super
simple and that the script was written
over the course of many years so what
would you say is the biggest difference
between where the idea started and what
we see in the final film
oh man this is hard to answer without
giving away a whole whole bunch of stuff
in the movie as you know it sort of like
evolves as the movie goes forward where
you know it's sort of there's a lot that
that happens um but the origin of the
movie really started i mean it's it's
really at its core it's a love story
between uh these two characters and um
it was brought about originally by uh my
uh sort of an examination of my
grandfather and uh grandmother's
relationship they met when they were and
started dating when they were 16 and
were together until they passed away a
few years ago and um
you know sort of this looking at uh
looking at
a
a couple's lives like this sort of love
story over the course of a lifetime um
yes there's these sort of like sci-fi
sprinkles and a bit of comedy here and
there uh obviously jim gaffigan is
in it uh but uh
but um but yeah again at its core it's
this love story and it sort of evolved
in that um
uh essentially my grandparents passed
away during the making of the the
writing of the script and so uh that
that moment sort of gave inspiration for
uh
for
i don't want to say the ending per se
but uh but a lot of how the the script
ended up changing throughout um was that
process oh it's a really beautiful
depiction of that so i can't
congratulate you enough on it um
jim and ray many questions about signing
on for this movie first you know tone
and style is just so so important to
pulling this whole concept off so what
were some of your biggest burning
questions for colin after reading the
script for the first time
we had many conversations about tone and
those continued uh with all three of us
and then separate conversations among
two of us or you know just constant
talking about tone because it is um it's
important in the film but it also
uh is
malleable in some ways in the film um
jim and i talked a lot about playing the
realism of each of these i call them
sort of fragmented snapshots
of
of a life of a life together that you
had to play the moment for what the
moment was
while understanding the sort of magical
realism element and the scope of how
it's fitting in to the whole
um
so we had questions about tone i also
had questions about logic i wanted i
wanted to make sure that i understood so
that i could bring
to the piece whatever
colin needed to tell that story um
[Music]
and then the more i understood that he
was
more interested in um
us bringing three-dimensional characters
to it and playing the love story than he
was in us trying to be clever about the
non-linear storytelling the more excited
i got
to get on board with that
yeah i was really excited uh when i read
the script and um there was a certain
amount of
you you you read a script and you're
like i hope that they're going about
this
in this manner my interpretation is
similar to how
they would go about this and
as we talked more and more about it uh
colin and i and then
ray and i it was
it was really uh amazing because it
it was um
even with things that i didn't imagine
it expanded kind of the scope of
the weight of it and you know you having
seen the movie it's like i talk about
like the last 10 minutes
you know because it's not really the
ending it's the last 10 minutes
and um
there is something about
that approach where i was i was shocked
that like everyone was on the same page
like when you get on a project you're
always ready for oh all right so this
guy wants me to do a silly robin
williams voice now here i mean or you
get in a situation and
someone wants to play the ending or
someone wants to play
the absence of affection between a
couple when it's far more interesting
that they do love each other and so
um i was very excited and it is it is
kind of corny but like we still enjoy
talking about it like the same kind of
energy we have
now about um
this movie and these characters is it's
almost identical to you know our initial
meeting and discussion discussions about
these these characters and their
relationships so how about meeting colin
in particular now and getting your first
impressions of him because it is a
second feature it's not his first
go-around but this is a mighty ambitious
film so what was it about his approach
maybe his past work that gave you two
the confidence that like yes this guy
here can do it well i think for me it's
it's some of it's the script
that
was so good
and also
uh
i didn't feel like when we were talking
initially he was guessing me
you know like there
i mean there is
also i mean look this was during a time
in the pandemic where
people were coming a little bit out of
hibernation to work so there was an
enthusiasm to work
but it was also one of those things
where i was leaving my wife with five
kids to work on this project so it had
to be uh something that made sense
but
yeah i think that like my first
impression was
this guy really cares a lot about this
project and he's not
no one's doing an indie film for any
other purpose then to they love the
project and they love
you know uh executing a creative idea
but like i knew that
right away when i was talking to him
that he it was super ambitious
you know the the final product is
amazing i didn't you know like i mean i
wasn't even sure that we were going to
be able to finish the movie during the
time like we were every we tested every
other day again this is before vaccines
it was an indie
if we got shut down that would have been
it so
there and there wasn't
you know
oh we'd have to replace the makeup
person the makeup person would have
infected everyone you know i mean so
there was uh an excitement about even
completing it right that was amazing
so this is all gravy yeah yeah we didn't
even think we'd get this far
yeah i would echo uh jim sentiment as a
script
script first i just found it
beautiful and i found it incredibly
ambitious um
and then talking to colin
we had long conversations prior to
meeting in person and jim's right i mean
it was a big i had to have a whole
conversation with my family about
leaving i live in l.a with
my husband and my stepsons and there was
no vaccines then and very few people
were trying to shoot and the ones that
were were doing big productions with
bubbles and
my kids were super helpful where they
were like do it just like the nba and i
was like we don't have their money and
they were like do it just like tyler
perry did i was like we don't have that
money either
like we're not building a barracks to
put us up so we were like well how are
we going to do this and it was a little
bit scary and then we had this
family environment
and pulled it off and then some um but
i knew i wanted to do it when i just i i
kept talking to my husband about it and
i kept talking to my reps about it and
then the conversations with colin he
also wrote a beautiful letter talking
about some of the um
personal experiences
that had fueled some of it but also some
of the philosophy behind it the
questions that
he was raising um and wanted to raise
discourse about
um
and when i called you and i said
i want your whole letter
to be in the subtext of of this script
and
i'd love to try to help tell the story
coming at it from that direction and
he
is
uh not a first time director but you're
right
new or ha like this is a very ambitious
film but um
i thought
if he had what a friend of mine calls
confident enough to collaborate and
that's that's colin in a nutshell like
definitely helms the ship and is a
wonderful leader and has vision and
wrote this and directed it but you're
also
so um
accepting of someone else bringing
something to the table and saying like
whether it's
um
art or it's camera or it's sound or it's
an actor you're uh
you're quick to say like is this if this
is helping the vision
more or helping it move forward then
then that's a yes it doesn't have to be
your idea which was lovely
well thanks for the kind words guys yeah
i mean we uh i tend to look at actors as
um honestly like department heads just
like all the other department heads the
the director photography or the this the
production designer um but they're the
production head or the sorry the
department head for their own character
um and i think in that way it becomes
just as collaborative of a process as
working with your dp or the sound
engineer or whatever
and not to make it technical i'm not
saying that but it's it's a conversation
like if i come in there just demanding
stuff like what's the point what's the
conversation i mean the whole point of
making these things is to spark these
conversations in the first place and so
i think there was a real joy in like the
day-to-day
examining of this film together as a
group um because it's like a
it's a convert it's sort of a
conversation piece and it's meant to
kind of have that that kind of an
outcome so i was i was thrilled to work
with these two both of whom um worked
beautiful individually and together i
think you guys have like such a
chemistry that was um
like that's nothing to do with me they
just kill it you know uh and uh it that
just makes my job so so much easier one
of my favorite things to ask about is
the value of a good scene partner and
that seems particularly important on a
film like this so jim and ray is there
anything that the other did for you on
the set of this film that proved
invaluable to your own performance that
you really appreciated
no no i i'm joking
here's the the
i
you know there's sometimes there's
uh you work with people
that don't want to
overthink things or you know and i'm
kind of i don't think i'm overthinking
things i or having discussing beats and
moments and relationships some people
don't want to do that
and you have to respect that
but there is also
um
you know look if we never discussed it
uh discuss what we had i think that we
could have done something but i think
with the the the collaboration and the
enthusiasm to collaborate
made the scenes fuller
and
so it was very exciting to
um
and you know the closer you get to
someone
you know then you you you know it
becomes a sense just
yeah yeah just have a conversation it's
not um and then you're not leaning
in to things you you can kind of just
communicate i don't know if i'm making
sense no you are yeah and i mean i i
feel the same like i there's yeah
there's definitely
you have to respect the process of
people that don't want to talk about it
and sort of break it down together um
but i feel like uh
especially in limited time there's um
there's a lot of bonding that happens
when you do break it down and and jim
and i both really like script analysis
and uh breaking things down in that
manner and it does for me and i found
that jim was the same way
it's not that that takes the magic of
the scene away some people think that if
you're calling it overthinking is going
to make it technical and instead i find
it very freeing and so does jim
and then the icing on that cake is
i have a
pronounced respect for the way he's
coming at his work and he's feeling that
mutual respect about mine and now you
feel safe to try things and to offer to
be the other person's setup if if it's
like oh we were also talking about that
maybe it would be interesting if cameron
you know what in simplified language
becomes angry by the end of it
i'm ready to say like okay how do i set
that up for you how do i make the arc
how do we get this snake to not
not force it and manipulate it but like
i have to change course as well and but
we wanted each other to try things and
so it makes for a safe space and what
happens is the takeaway is the audience
sees
texture between lines the whole time
that's the result of that is it looks
like two people listening to each other
because we are because if you're going
to hit your ball slightly to the left
then i'm going to catch it slightly to
the left and it and it keeps modulating
that way whatever the process was here
worked really well everything came
together so incredibly beautifully i
wish so badly we could reconnect when
the movie comes out so we could talk
spoilers because i have a million and
one questions about what this movie
really is but cannot recommend linoleum
enough huge congratulations to the three
of you and thank you for chatting with
us about your movie
you